Deku was born quirkless but he acquires  seven different quirks including one for  all a transferable Quirk that gives its  users super strength and super speed and  gets stronger over time black whip lets  him generate black tendrils from his  body and use them to attack or restrain  an opponent float allows him to levitate  through the air danger sense is like a  spidey sense and it lets him identify  threats in the surrounding area smoke  screen lets him generate smoke all  around him farjin allows him to build up  kinetic energy and release superhuman  bursts of strength and speed and gear  shift allows him to shift the speed of  anything he touches literally defying  the laws of physics for a detailed  explanation of every Quirk and every  former one for all user check out my  full length video link in the  description